>>> THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING JANUARY 6th IS
MOVING SWIFTLY TO ADDRESS A
DRAFT EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM 2020
THAT WOULD HAVE ORDERED THE
MILITARY TO SEIZE VOTING
MACHINES.
COMMITTEE CHAIR BENNIE THOMPSON
SAYS THEY'VE SPOKEN TO FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR.
>> TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL ALREADY.
WE'VE TALKED TO DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE INDIVIDUALS.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT OUR
MILITARY WAS PART OF THIS BIG
LIE ON PROMOTING THAT THE
ELECTION WAS FALSE.
SO IF YOU'RE USING THE MILITARY
TO POTENTIALLY SEIZE VOTING
MACHINES, EVEN THOUGH IT'S A
DISCUSSION, THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO
KNOW.
>> AND BARR STEPPED DOWN IN THE
SAME MONTH THAT THIS DRAFT ORDER
WAS APPARENTLY PUT TOGETHER
AFTER HE BROKE RANKS BY
REJECTING TRUMP'S ELECTION
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND LIES.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH CNN POLITICAL
ANALYST CARL BERNSTEIN.
HIS GREAT NEW MEMOIR IS CALLED
"CHASING HISTORY: A KID IN THE
NEWSROOM."
CARL, I'M LOVING IT SO FAR.
APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON.
FIRST I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
BILL BARR COOPERATING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE.
THAT IS A FASCINATING
DEVELOPMENT, IS IT NOT?
>> WELL, YES.
AND WE'VE GOT TO KNOW THE EXTENT
OF THE COOPERATION.
BUT HE WAS IN THE POSITION TO
KNOW AN AWFUL LOT ABOUT WHAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS DOING TO STAGE
A COUP.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE NEED TO
SAY ABOUT THIS INVESTIGATION IS
ALREADY WE KNOW HOW SERIOUS THE
INVESTIGATION IS.
WE KNOW IT'S TURNED UP A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
THAT NOT ONLY SUGGESTS THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS INTENT ON
STAGING A COUP, IT'S PRETTY
DEFINITIVE AT THIS POINT.
WE ALSO KNOW MEMBERS OF THE VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE'S STAFF ARE
COOPERATING WITH THE COMMITTEE.
A PICTURE IS ALREADY STARTING TO
EMERGE OF A CRIMINAL, SEDITIOUS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
UNPRECEDENTED IN OUR HISTORY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE CIVIL
WAR TO FIND THE KIND OF SEDITION
OCCURRING AT A HIGH LEVEL IN OUR
GOVERNMENT SUCH AS OCCURRED ON
JANUARY 6th AND RIGHT AFTER THE
ELECTION.
AND THINK BACK TO THE SEDITION
OF THE CONFEDERACY.
THAT WAS LED BY A MEMBER OF THE
CONGRESS, NOT BY A PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
AND THE FACT THAT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAS NOT PARTICIPATED IN
THIS INVESTIGATION, HAS JUST
DECIDED THEY WILL THROW IN THEIR
LOT WITH DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
CRIMINALITY, TELLS US AN AWFUL
LOT ABOUT WHERE THIS REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS TODAY AND HOW TRUMP HAS
THEM UNDER HIS LOCK AND KEY.
>> AND CARL, I DO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT YOUR BOOK, BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE A LOT OF LESSONS
IN THERE THAT I THINK WOULD BE
INSTRUCTIVE TODAY.
IT'S IN ITS FIRST WEEK, ALREADY
ON THE TOP TEN OF THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" BESTSELLER LIST,
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE LOOK AT YOUR
CAREER PRE-WATERGATE.
AT ONE POINT YOU OFFER DETAILS
ON BEING ON THE DICTATION DESK
WHICH YOUNGER VIEWERS MIGHT NOT
BE FAMILIAR WITH.
YOU WERE ON THE DICTATION DESK
AS NEWS OF THE KENNEDY
ASSASSINATION WERE COMING IN.
YOU WROTE, MY HANDS WERE
SHAKING, THIS IS AS YOU WERE
TAKING DICTATION COMING IN FROM
A REPORTER ON THE IS A
ASSASSINATION, AND I MISTYPED
"HOSPITAL" WITHOUT HAVING TIME
TO CORRECT IT.
THE WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCED THE
PRESIDENT HAD DIED AT 1:00
CENTRAL TIME.
KENNEDY HAD BEEN GIVEN THE LAST
RITES BY ONE OF THE PRIESTS.
A FEW SECONDS LATER THE WIRE
ROOM BELLS WENT HAYWIRE WITH THE
FLASH THAT THE PRESIDENT REALLY
WAS DEAD.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE NEWSROOMS
ABOUT THAT ERA THAT WE SHOULD BE
LEARNING FROM AT THIS POINT IN
OUR HISTORY?
>> LET ME FIRST SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS BOOK, "CHASING
HISTORY," BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
ABOUT THIS KID, ME, WHO GOT THE
BEST SEAT IN THE COUNTRY AT AGE
16.
I WENT TO WORK AS A COPY BOY AT
"THE WASHINGTON EVENING STAR,"
THE GREATEST AFTERNOON PAPER IN
AMERICA AT THE TIME, THE
OPPOSITION BETTER AND A BETTER
PAPER THAN "THE WASHINGTON POST"
IN THOSE DAYS.
WHAT THIS MEMOIR IS ABOUT IS
THIS FIVE YEARS FROM 1960 TO '65
WHEN HUGE EVENTS ARE HAPPENING
IN THE NATION, NOT JUST THE
INAUGURATION AND THE ELECTION OF
KENNEDY, HIS ASSASSINATION,
WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT IN A
SECOND, THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT, THE PASSAGE OF THE
VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
I WAS ABLE TO COVER AS A
19-YEAR-OLD KID.
AND THINK OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IN THE CONGRESS OF THE
UNITED STATES, TO STRIP AWAY --
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WANTS TO
STRIP AWAY THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT
THAT WAS PASSED IN 1965.
SO IT'S ABOUT THIS KID THAT GETS
THE BEST SEAT IN THE COUNTRY,
GETS TO SEE THESE PRESIDENTS
FIRSTHAND, AND WRITE AND REPORT
ON ALL THE GREAT EVENTS IN THE
COUNTRY, REALLY IN MY TEENAGE
YEARS.
AND BEFORE WATERGATE, BEFORE
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
AND THERE'S NOT A WORD IN THIS
AFTER 1965.
IT'S NOT THE OLD MAN LOOKING
BACK.
IT'S WRITTEN IN THE VOICE OF THE
KID.
AND ON THE DATE OF THE
ASSASSINATION, I CAME DOWN TO
THE NEWSROOM, I HEARD THE NEWS
WHILE I WAS IN A CLASS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND, AND THE
REPORTER WAS RUNNING OUT THE
DOOR AND SHE SAID TO ME, "HE'S
DEAD."
IT HAD NOT BEEN ANNOUNCED YET
THAT HE WAS DEAD.
I SAID, HOW DO YOU KNOW?
SHE SAID, JERRY O'LEARY'S
BROTHER WHO WORKS AT THE CIA,
AND O'LEARY WAS A GREAT REWRITE
MAN AT THE "STAR," GOT IT FROM
HIS BROTHER.
I RAN UPSTAIRS TO THE NEWSROOM.
THE NATIONAL EDITOR -- BECAUSE
HE KNEW I COULD TYPE PRETTY MUCH
FASTER THAN ANYBODY AT 90 WORDS
A MINUTE, SAID, BERNSTEIN,HEADS
TAKE DAVID BRODER FROM DALLAS.
I PUT ON MY HEADSET AND HE
STARTED TO DICTATE AND HE SAID,
TWO PRIESTS WALKED OUT OF DALLAS
PARKLAND MEMORIAL HOSPITAL AND
ANNOUNCE, COMMA QUOTE, THE
PRESIDENT IS DEAD.
I MISSPELLED "HOSPITAL," AS YOU
INDICATED, BECAUSE MY HANDS WERE
SHAKING SO BAD.
BUT RIGHT AFTER THAT, I WAS TOLD
BY THE CITY EDITOR TO RIGHT AWAY
GO UP TO THE CAPITOL TO TRY AND
FIND SPEAKER McCORMICK WHO WAS
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND THE
NEXT IN LINE AFTER THE VICE
PRESIDENT LYNDON JOHNSON WHO HAD
BEEN SWORN IN AS PRESIDENT OR
WAS BEING SWORN IN, AND TO FIND
SPEAKER McCORMICK.
I WAS TOLD HE WAS HIDING UNDER
HIS DESK.
I FINALLY FOUND HIM SURROUNDED
BY A PHALANX OF CAPITOL HILL
POLICE.
FROM THERE I WAS SENT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TO WAIT FOR THE BODY
TO COME BACK TO COVER THE PEOPLE
IN LAFAYETTE SQUARE ACROSS THE
STREET WHO WERE SOBBING.
CROWDS WERE GATHERING.
I COVERED THE ASSASSINATION
THROUGH THE WEEKEND.
IT'S JUST AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT
THESE WONDERFUL PEOPLE WITH THIS
GREAT NEWSPAPER LET ME DO, EVEN
THOUGH WHEN I WENT TO WORK
THERE, I HAD ONE FOOT IN THE
POOL HALL, ONE FOOT IN THE
JUVENILE COURT, AND TWO INCHES
OF A FOOT IN THE CLASSROOM.
SO IT'S ABOUT THIS KID WHO GETS
THIS AMAZING SEAT AND WHAT HE
LEARNS, WHICH IS EVERYTHING THAT
WOODWARD AND I DID IN WATERGATE.
YOU CAN SEE HOW IN "ALL THE
PRESIDENT'S MEN" WE TALK ABOUT
THE BEST OBTAINABLE VERSION OF
THE TRUTH.
IT COMES FROM WHAT I LEARNED AT
"THE STAR."
SO THE LINES ARE CLEAR.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT A REPORTER DOES,
PERSEVERANCE, KNOCK ON DOORS,
LEARN TO MAKE SOURCES, HOW YOU
DEAL WITH THOSE SOURCES.
AND SO IT'S A BOOK ABOUT ANOTHER
TIME IN AMERICA, ANOTHER TIME IN
JOURNALISM.
AND YET THOSE BASIC TECHNIQUES
ARE THE REASON WE HAVE SEEN IN
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY THE
GREATEST REPORTING ON A
PRESIDENCY IN MY LIFETIME BY THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS, BECAUSE THAT
METHODOLOGY, THAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY WE KNOW
FROM THE REPORTING, NOT FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> AND IT'S SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
AND CARL, WE'RE SO FORTUNATE
THAT YOU STAYED OUT OF THAT POOL
HALL AND YOU STAYED IN THE
NEWSROOM AND LEARNED THE CRAFT
AND LEARNED THE TRADE, BECAUSE
WE ARE ALL THE BETTER FOR IT.
CARL BERNSTEIN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
CHECK OUT HIS GREAT NEW BOOK